okay great to be here you've heard about
culture you've heard about law I'm going
to get into politics and show us that we
think about food in what are seen to be
somewhat radically different words and
this title between two worlds is not
made up by me but by made up by people
who actually live and breathe and eat in
the worlds of food so if you're in that
world and get emails with the regularity
that I get you get messages from these
worlds with some regularity so just the
other day I got a message about a new
report that had appeared a policymakers
guide to the GMO controversies and it
goes on in somewhat heightened rhetoric
but unfortunately the continued
development of GMOs has been endangered
by neo-luddite opposition supported by a
series of media generated controversy so
these are terms that appear kind of
frequently on that side of the discourse
but the same week I got another email
about a book that's been published about
EPA's failure to deal with pesticide
chemicals in an appropriate way and
there you see that part of the charge is
that the result of EPA's misbehavior is
a complex and elaborate illusion of
government mental precaution which
ultimately gives the petrochemical
industries and agribusiness free rein so
the same business the same business that
produces GMOs and other agricultural
products is caused in radically
different ways in these kinds of things
and you have to take my word as a
qualitative researcher who has never
done the statistics that I get this
several times in a month so what's going
on here one of the presuppositions of my
field of politics of Science and
Technology is to start with the
presumption that if people are genuinely
upset about things then methodologically
you
should not go in knowing what they're
upset about that this is actually
something you should be asking them so
in this domain of GMOs and food
production you find if you go in with
that sort of neutral presumption that
there are all kinds of claims being made
about the technology and about what it's
going to do for us so one of those
claims is that it's going to make nature
better it's going to make it more
orderly behave right weeds won't be in
the wrong places and so on and so forth
and therefore we will get much more
yield per hectare and per plant and
generally be in a far better position to
feed a world where the population is
growing but the total planetary surface
of arable land is not growing so we need
to get more and more out of there and we
have to make nature behave better so
that is certainly one kind of claim that
you get another sort of claim is in that
phrase neo-luddite I don't know why the
people who wrote that policy report put
it in quotations but I'm borrowing their
quotations where are these neo-luddites
well they're uprooting plants in if you
recognize the cultural position of that
pay farmers you will know that this is
Britain you may not know instantly that
it's a peer of the realm whose uprooting
the plants but if you've been watching
Downton Abbey you will know that the
relationship between the aristocracy and
the mere bobbies is something that is
itself culturally embedded and perhaps
not the easiest thing to understand but
in any case the neo-luddites here are
people who are in positions a very
considerable power and prestige if you
go across the channel to a different
place you will find that Germans are
also protesting against GMOs but they're
doing it in a different sort of way
through artwork positioned in front of a
building which again if you have the
cultural knowledge you will recognise is
the houses of parliament so the very
same debate that's playing out in
America on the fields where you're
remaking nature is playing out in
Britain in class related conflicts about
the place of nature and in Germany as a
legislative sort of debate so what is at
stake here and if we go in
without the sort of presupposition that
it's the neo-luddites and the anti
scientists or whatever we might say that
there are kinds of innovation going on
here
that are about the kinds of politics
that people want and from that
standpoint my own research looks cross
nationally and comparatively at the kind
of politics that people have constructed
around agricultural technologies so what
are these worlds when they are apart
from each other one way to think about
them is the way the political
commentator and public intellectual
Robert Kagan has written about them
which is that Europe is just a totally
different world on a day when I learned
shortly ago that dr. Spock has died you
know maybe we think about different
worlds in slightly different terms but
in any case Hagen also thinks about it
in sort of star trekky terms he think
European thinks Europeans are from Venus
and Americans are from Mars but the
language is this it's time to stop
pretending that we share a common view
of the world or even that they occupy
the same world well if you take a
somewhat more sensitized view of the
politics you might end up concluding
that in America we're suffering from
something that we typically think of as
denialism we typically attach it to
climate but you might conclude that be
also attach it to GMOs this is a slide
that lists out a number of episodes in
which GMOs have not behaved in the way
that they behave
now typically we think it's kind of anti
scientific to give different
explanations for the same behavior all
the time instead we look for
regularities but if you look at these
GMO escaped cases you find that
different public explanations have been
given for each one suggesting that some
generality possibly is being missed if
you investigate further you will find
that across the three countries that
I've described Britain Germany and the
u.s. they're very different cultures of
expectation about how public knowledge
gets generated and who counts as an
expert and how
we test expertise so I am not showing
this to you for the sake of telling you
what's in each box of the matrix but to
suggest that if we are worlds apart it's
not because someone's from Venus and
someone's from Mars that that we have
actually quite different expectations
about how to run our politics in
relation to expertise how we generate
trust around technical claims and at the
end of the day what kinds of products we
want to put into our bodies on the basis
of those claims so I will conclude by
saying that the question what kinds of
foods do we want reduces or translates
into my kind of research into a slightly
different question which is what kinds
of politics and ethics do we want thank
you